der partitur ist der hat jetzt gar
keinen spaß mehr
was ist da genau jetzt passiert nachdem
lockdown ja viele haben sich haben sich
durch die wortwahl angegriffen gefühlt
asozialer deutscher tourist asozialer
tourist und ich meine viele von uns
gehen auch hochrangigen jobs nach sind
abteilungsleiter in firmen oder am
eigene lokale und die wollen sich das
halt auch nicht bieten lassen die tragen
wirklich teilweise wirklich tausende
euros im jahr hin und machen das auch
gerne machen das auch weil wir hier spaß
und haben uns zusammen sind aber die
haben dann auch gesagt was was bringt
uns das was unterscheidet uns jetzt was
unterscheidet den ballermann 6 jetzt von
anderen urlaubsinsel oder urlaubs
abschnitten strandabschnitten wenn der
bierkönig und diese kultstätten nicht
mehr da sind und da kann man auch könnte
man genauso gut nach ich sage jetzt mal
ibiza in griechenland egal wohin fliegen
da ist dann auch strand und meer und das
sind halt wirklich diese kultstätten für
die man dann extra gegen kommt und
deswegen sind dann halt auch viele
abgereist oder haben halt auch storniert
hat auch aus enttäuschung und wut über
die über die spanische regierung der
balearen regierung dass er solche wörter
gefallen sind und verletzt ein land
irgendwo